on
8 mars 1917 février dans le calendrier
russes les rues petrograd sont noirs de
protestataires les ouvriers des usines
de munitions sont en guerre
la foule pillent les boulangeries
incendies les postes de police
les soldats de la garnison de petrograd
qui ont d'abord tiré sur le peuple lève
la croissance en l'air et exigeons
l'abdication du tsar et de son épouse
l'allemande c'est la révolution une
révolution spontanée
à
la révolution les idéalistes les
démocrates les socialistes les
anarchistes russes en ont rêvé pendant
plusieurs décades
c'est la révolution et elle n'a pas de
chef les soldats montent la garde dans
les couloirs de la douma les députés à
la hâte désigne les membres d'un
gouvernement provisoire
leur chef nominal est un noble le prince
of ses ministres sont des modérés
le membre le plus actif de ce
gouvernement provisoire est un avocat
libéral très ambitieux guérin ski
et
à moscou comme à petrograd les troupes
font allégeance ou nouveau gouvernement
au front il expliqua blement calme
depuis plusieurs mois on arrose
copieusement à la vodka la révolution
des régiments qui est déserte
pour éviter l'assassinât du tsar ou son
éventuelle évasion il est mis sous bonne
garde avec sa famille
le 15 mars il haptique en faveur de son
frère michael 1 allemande pressant de
carence qui michael ossi abdique la
dynastie des romanov s'est écroulé en
quelques heures
pour les prisonniers politiques du
régime tsariste révolution signifie
liberté
dans un mouvement de générosité à
contrôler queyras qui donne toute
liberté à l'extrême gauche de reparaître
au grand jour les bolcheviks ressorte
ils sont dans la rue avec lehman chez
vic voici plekhanov le fondateur du
marxisme à russie et zinovyev qui
rendent de 9 ans d'exil en suisse autre
exilé radec vétéran de la révolution
manquée de 1905
kameneff rendre de sibérie un bolchevik
scriabine 27 ans se fait appeler molotov
il édite la pravda une feuille
bolchevique yosef vissarionovitch
djougachvili à 38 ans il se fait appeler
staline l'homme d'acier en russe
il revient aussi des camps sibérien
l'efs bronstein connu sous le nom de
trotsky était exilé dans le bronx à new
york le plus connu les agitateurs
soviétique bas la semelle dans les rues
de zurich
vladimir ilitch oulianov se prépare à
rentrer dans son pays
dieu seul sait comment
pour lénine dieu est tellement il a reçu
berlin de l'argent des papiers des
promesses alexandre alphonse maître
espion allemand finances en russie la
propagande de lénine
fritz plat tu n as socialiste suisse
arrange avec les allemands le transport
de lénine à travers l'allemagne dans le
fameux vin comptes plombés lénine et ses
compagnons sync une décharge ils sont
volontaires pour l'opération en avril
1917 lénine et en russie le gouvernement
allemand dont la patience
le président wilson vient de lui
déclarer la guerre les ruses doit faire
la paix tout de suite
lénine descend du train la gare de
finlande le 16 avril 1917 ou site où il
parle à la foule de petrograd il dénonce
la guerre des pirates
la guerre des impérialistes il attaque
le nouveau gouvernement russe un
télégramme informe berlin que lénine
travaille dans le sens prévu
pour l'émission à lier à petersburg la
révolution est une énigme où ira-t-elle
les alliés sont soulagés certes d'être
débarrassé de la corruption des tsars
mais ils veulent maintenir dans la
guerre le nouveau régime mais états unis
offre 300 millions de dollars de crédits
elio route anciens secrétaires d'état
engagée par wilson pèse de tout son
poids sur les rays qui pas de guerre pas
de crédit
tiens ce qui s'est fait nommer ministre
de la guerre il veut à tout prix éviter
la défaite il se précipite sur le front
autrichien le plus facile à percer de
nouveaux le général bruce enough prépare
une offensive de nouveau il perce les
lignes autrichienne et réalise une
avance sérieuse de nouveau les canons
allemands tom et brise l'assaut cette
fois c'en est fini
l'armée russe les allemands ne se soucie
plus de faire des prisonniers
ils les laissent pourrir les bolcheviks
de petrograd accueilli avec joie la
nouvelle du désastre il contrôle les
soviets d'ouvriers de soldats ils les
mobilise les compagnons de lénine sont
en train de construire leur pouvoir
le 17 juillet 1917 ils se manifestent
leur slogan à bas le gouvernement car à
skis tout le pouvoir aux soviets les
soldats tirent ni lénine ni les
bolcheviks ne sont touchés
il n'était pas dans les rangs du peuple
le gouvernement qui rend ce qui
s'écroule le gouvernement des bolcheviks
et dispersées lénine s'enfuit en
finlande trotski est arrêté quiros qui a
retourné la situation
il devient premier ministre mais son
gouvernement est de nouveau menacée par
la droite cette fois en septembre son
principal général kornilov tourner
casaque
il veut prendre petrograd
guérin ce qu'ils appellent la gauche au
secours et lui fournit des armes
les soldates kornilov l'abandonnent le
coup est manqué mais les bolcheviks sont
désormais en armes ils disposent d'une
force militaire
les cartes rouges au cours des semaines
leurs leaders sont libérés lénine rente
triomphalement de finlande de nouveau la
menace terrasse qui tente de rassembler
ses forces défaillante pour défendre son
gouvernement
ils défendent est ainsi la première et
dernière tentative de gouvernement
démocratique qui ait jamais vu le jour
en russie petrograd attendait en fait
une deuxième révolution
on
non
le 7 novembre 1917 la révolution est au
rendez vous presque trop facile
la ville a perdu tout désir de
résistance les équipes entraînées de
bolcheviks s'empare des points clés le
telegraph la poste et banques les gars
il ne rend compte de résistance qu'au
palais d'hiver les gardes rouges
s'empare rapidement des ministres
seule carence qui parvient à s'échapper
le jour suivant la ville est aux mains
des bolcheviks et lénine prend la parole
nous allons maintenant construire le
socialisme dit et
premier acte de la révolution communiste
lénine affirme la russie va maintenant
faire la paix la paix immédiate et ils
dénoncent tous les traités conclus avec
les à lille trotsky son âme damnée
obtient l'accord empressé des allemands
qui lui donne rendez-vous à brest
litovsk haute ce qui est surpris
horrifié par les exigences de berlin
la russie doit céder un quart de son
territoire d'avant la guerre un tiers de
sa population la moitié de ces
industries et la plupart de ses défenses
les russes cherchent à gagner du temps
ils ne signent pas tout de suite mais
les armées allemandes s'ébranle vers
petrograd
il cite alors au moment où ils sonnent
entre dans la guerre la russie s'en
retire
sans les russes les alliés ne pouvait
tenir contre une armée allemande
renforcé de ses divisions de l'est
wilson devait sauver leur guerre la
première dynastie européenne venait de
disparaître celle des romanov ne
s'arrêtait captif de la révolution des
rouges qui risque est de gagner toutes
les russies
il serait bientôt assassiné avec toute
sa famille
la révolution russe pose un problème à
toute l'europe l'angleterre et la france
vont elles échapper à la révolution
est ce qu'elles peuvent se maintenir
dans la guerre
les alliés sont ils assez solides pour
tenir en attendant le secours des
américains 400000 tobin sont déjà morts
à la guerre au 1er janvier 1917 il faut
trouver chaque semaine cinq mille recrue
pour combler les vides
la guerre devient terriblement
impopulaires les masses sont au bord de
la révolte pas d'orchestre à paris ou à
londres pour le retour des blessés du
front
les arrières tiendront-ils
des anglais heureusement n'était pas
sale il avait le secours des dominions
les canadiens les indiens les sud
africains les néo zélandais et les
australiens ont fait plus que leur
devoir pour aider l'angleterre
même les dissidents irlandais ont
répondu à l'appel aux armes
deux cent mille se sont enrôlés
e
et secours venus de double à son
chaleureux mais trompeur des signes de
rébellion se manifeste en irlande
nous ne servons ni leroy 1000e kayser
disent les volontaires irlandais mais
l'irlande
ils servent à la fois aux côtés des
anglais en france et aussi
malheureusement contre les anglais sur
le front intérieur
les garnisons britanniques en irlande se
croyait tranquille quand se préparer
l'offensive de la somme les anglais
croyait tenir sous leur contrôle le
mouvement nationaliste irlandais
beaucoup de nationalistes furent eux
mêmes surpris par la rébellion de dublin
le dernier lundi de l'année 10 216
roger casement le chef nationaliste
irlandais n'est pas pour les anglais
très clair parce qu'il le soupçonne de
flirter avec les allemands les autres
chefs rebelles proclame la république
libre d'irlande
les anglais attaquent les bâtiments où
se sont en tranches et les rebelles
considérant le soulèvement comme un coup
de poignard dans le dos il estime que
les irlandais doivent se satisfaire de
leur statut d'autonomie jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre avec l'allemagne mais les
rôles belle en appel à un sacrifice du
sang pour que l'irlande puisse renaître
450d leur sont tués pour 100 en anglais
seulement
dans les ruines des incendies allumés
par les obus les chefs rebelles exigent
cependant six jours ils doivent
finalement accepté la reddition sans
condition submergé par le nombre
les patriots irlandais sont durement
frappés
quinze d'entre eux sont exécutés un seul
leader parvient à s'échapper
emon de valera d'origine américaine 2000
sont exilés en grande bretagne
pour tenter d'atténuer le choc lloyd
george est désigné comme médiateur dans
les négociations qui s'ouvrent avec les
irlandais il gagne du temps il promet
l'amnistié
djordje est un ambitieux qui ne fait pas
de cadeau
quelques mois plus tard il aura la peau
de herbert tarifs et prendra son poste
premier ministre le bouillon lloyd
george a réussi à amadouer les irlandais
pourra-t-il écarté le spectre de la
révolution dans l'angleterre ruiné par
la guerre l'année 1917 est la plus dure
londres est sinistre des visages des
passants sont fermés
le pays peut seulement nourrir sa
population de la nuit du vendredi
jusqu'au lundi matin pour les autres
jours de la semaine il faut apporter des
vivres les lignes du ravitaillement sont
attaqué sans relâche par les sous marins
pour utiliser les stocks défaillante
vives pour être certain que les enfants
au moins pour au sourire le gouvernement
sert des repas préparés dans les
cuisines nationale il impose le
rationnement pour toutes les denrées
seul le sucre est maintenant en vente
libre jusqu'en 1918 pour ne pas
désespérer les pauvres faire la queue
devient une routine les pommes de terre
sont si rares que les riches en offre
plutôt que des fleurs aux maîtresses de
maison
on manque de lait le lait est interdit
aux adultes mais il n'y en a pas encore
accès pour les enfants pas d'essence le
gaz de charbon est mesuré une génération
entière de citoyens britanniques est
balayée par les pertes de la guerre en
1917 seuls les vieux les femmes et les
enfants tiennent le front de l'intérieur
non
à
les collégiens préparent leur départ un
accueil des classes entières de
conscrits sont balayées les enfants en
attendant leur incorporation sont soumis
à toutes les corvées
ils travaillent dans les fermes à la
ville ils font des collectes
il n'y a pas de jaune assez jeune pour
ne pas servir le roi et le pays
la dernière illusion tombe pas de
sécurité sur le front intérieur les et
plat les aéroplanes tiennent le ciel au
début les gens sortent dans les rues
pour les voir bientôt il se cache à leur
approche en 1917 3000 civils sont tués
ou blessés par les bombes tomber du ciel
georges le nouveau premier ministre
garde pour lui son découragement
il paraît en public dynamique est résolu
s'il exige des sacrifices du front de
l'intérieur il veut diminuer les pertes
en france il prétend lever la conduite
de la guerre à ses généraux il n'a pas
confiance en eux il est très attentif
aux décisions du chef du corps
expéditionnaire britannique qui lui
paraît incompétence heures douglas fake
mais il doit le ménage et c'est une
favorite georges 5 le jazz le trouve
maladroit insensible aux pertes même si
elles sont énormes
il lui préfère le français nivelles
auquel elle est subordonnée nivelles a
présenté un plan pour la victoire rapide
et sûre reid a remplacé geof comme
généralissime nivelles propose une
double offensive au nord pour les
britanniques au sud pour les français
les anglais doivent attaquer sur un race
le 9 avril 1917
m
ouais
la rupture du franc c'est la vieille
balançoires des généraux
à l'extrémité de la ligue anglaise des
hauteurs de vimy une avancée du front
déjà des milliers de victimes et
canadiennes sont chargés de s'en emparer
d'y enterrer c'est un enfer le très
lourdes pertes mais nivelles nivelles
qui a promis la victoire en 48 heures
il ne se soucie ni de la surprise ni de
la météo sans importance d'été pour une
armée décidé à vaincre
polytechnicien l'hiver elle a fait ses
calculs le coût ne peut pas manquer
c'est du moins ce qu'il dit
après une violente préparation
d'artillerie dont on attend monts et
merveilles 40 division française s'est
lancé tombe dans le vide
l'ennemi a restreint céline cacher ses
défenses et français se font massacrer
au chemin des dames
deux cent mille morts en quelques jours
soldats français après ce drame vont se
mutiner
ils veulent désormais faire la grève de
la guerre troubles et seth rogen casser
trop de gaz et sur toute la ligne les
régimes ans mutine
est ce la révolution dans les tranchées
jamais plus les généraux français
n'oseront demandé une offensive
baïonnette au canon les points ne sont
pas des bolcheviks
ils en ont seulement marre de la guerre
cinquante cinq divisions sont affectée
par les mutineries
aucun leader révolutionnaire au front le
mouvement est spontané les politiques
pense que ce mouvement peut être
terminée
oh
on
c'est pétain qui prend les choses en
main 554 condamné à mort mais seulement
45 exécuté pétain revoil régime des
permissions et la rotation des unités en
première ligne les officiers sont
désormais conscients qu'ils ne peuvent
ordonner que des actions limitées et
bien préparé ils doivent reprendre en
main la troupe mais rentrent sa
confiance dans le commandement
les officiers anglais doivent aussi
faire face à des révoltes les allemands
eux-mêmes changer unités du front il se
défie des recrues qui viennent de
l'intérieur
partout on craint la révolution
radieux
ah la la
adieu tout mais ça
c'est là fini
c'est pour toujours
de cette guerre
c'est pas un
c'est le travail
un vent assez sympa
nous savons tous qu'en mai
le soir
et ça
en angleterre la propagande guerrière
fait beaucoup de bruit mais les gens
montrent assez les prix ont doublé les
sous-marins sont plus actifs que jamais
les ouvriers sont pris par le
recrutement pour remplir les vides des
unités les manifestations organisées
pour soutenir l'effort de guerre en pour
slogan gagné la guerre mais qui les
écoutent encore dans le désarroi des
esprits ailleurs ancrée fini c'est la
guerre les mouvements protestation
explose un peu partout les mineurs vote
la grève
sur tous les bassins l'angleterre les
ouvriers des usines de munitions les
suivent
détesté par la clique militaires
suspects aux yeux des politiques est peu
appréciée par le roi le d'orge passe
pour un dictateur mais il réussit à
rassembler la nation pour le dernier
effort à briser les grèves
révolutionnaire il engagea conservateur
churchill connu pour son énergie il
était en disgrâce depuis la malheureuse
affaire des dardanelles et bien il
reprend aujourd'hui notre george hotz
talent au ministère des munitions
le lion est en place il n'arrêtera pas
de rugir
le roi lui même est attaqué sa cour est
pleine d'étrangers dit en allemand qu
d'esprit combatif le roy réplique qu'il
soit années qu'il est étranger il change
le nom de la maison royale qui était
d'origine allemande
il l'appelle désormais maison de windsor
ainsi pense que personne ne pourra plus
critiques qui la famille royale il
annonce un changement décisif dans la
guerre navale
le pays attend une politique nouvelle
sur mer pour lutter contre les
sous-marins une mission vient d'arriver
des états unis conduite par l'amiral
william sims sim s'est indigné par
l'importance des pertes des années sur
mer il réussit à convaincre l'amirauté
que la réponse à la menace sous marine
c'est l'organisation des convois la
grande bretagne n'a plus que six
semaines de vivre elle décide
d'appliquer le plan sims en peu de temps
les pertes sont réduites de moitié
washington est maintenant convaincu
qu'on peut envoyer en france une grande
armée mais celle-ci n'existe pas encore
en attendant les américains aig veux
courir la chance de sa vie on
l'autorisent à lancer une offensive
seulement britannique sur ton front
c'est la troisième offensive des
flandres un risque politique énorme
après la période des mutineries et gâte
accra sur la ligne de crête messi na pa
chaîne d'al il poussera en avant pour
libérer les ports de belgique est
terminée la guerre avant que les
allemands ne percevront france est
affaiblie la plus grande opération de
creusement de tunnels de la guerre est
entreprise à messine en face des lignes
allemandes les mineurs du pays de galles
le pays claude georges viennent
renforcer les sapeurs du génie pour
réussir la plus énorme opération de sape
de toute la guerre en secret il perd 19
tunnel il met en place 500 tonnes
d'explosifs au dessous les positions
allemandes
le coup d'envoi est donné à l'aube du 7
juin 1917 de londres lojack j'entends
l'explosion à plus de 200 kilomètres de
là au 10 downing street à sa résidence
de premier ministre les vitres tremble
vingt mille allemands sont tués ou
estropiées on capture 7000 prisonniers
totalement choquées elles demandent la
permission d'attaquer sur la crête de
pain chantal
notre georges d'abord s'y refuse et puis
s'y résignent il a un mauvais
pressentiment grande offensive commence
en juillet 1917 sur un champ de bataille
transformer en fonderie hier par des
torrents de pluie des troubles au but
les allemands sont enterrés
il dispose de canons lourds
les assaillants s'épuise une nouvelle
stratégie seront sur le terrain détrempé
des flandres
un général britannique visite en plus
tard le champ de bataille
s'écrie bon dieu nous avons réellement
envoyer des hommes combattent là dedans
pendant quatre mois d'automne la
bataille continue sans merci et prétend
qu'il a réussi à percer le front c'est
faux il a pris le pont de pas chaîne
d'al mais le front n'est pas percé et
les pertes sont innombrables et guette
un grand chirurgien ni churchill en
grinçant des temps et il ajoute sa haute
capacité professionnelle l'empêchent de
voir l'agonie de son patient
non
trois cent mille britanniques sont tués
blessés ou disparus dans la boue et gars
seulement gagner quelques arpente
marécages
oh
m
toutes les femmes d'angleterre se
dévouent pour les blessés et leurs
torches distribuer les décorations
survivants il n'a pas pu éviter la
dernière offensive de leurs règles mais
il a du moins éviter à son pays
martyrisé le plus grand de tous les maux
la révolution on peut redouter quand
1217 l'allemagne de keyser ne s'y
précipitent l'europe entière va-t-elle
tourner au rouge
pour conjurer le danger révolutionnaire
le pouvoir civil en allemagne haptique
de plus en plus en face des militaires
massifs et rassurant hindenburg héros
national et pour l'allemagne l'image du
père une volonté d'acier mais protecteur
responsable il a pour adjoint le
quartier-maître général erich von
ludendorff qui est après hindenburg
l'homme le plus puissant d'allemagne
les listes des héros morts ou blessés
s'allonge
notre seule fierté a coutume de dire le
2 nov
et que nous combattons face à des forces
très supérieure et que nos lignes sont
en dehors de notre territoire sacré
c'est un faible réconfort pour une
nation qui craquent les fondecave pour
se chauffer l'hiver et qui est aux
portes de la famille
les allemands sortent tous les jours
pour voir affichés sur les portes des
mairies les listes des morts des
disparus des prisonniers tout est
rationnée en allemagne le recrutement
enlève les mineurs et des fermiers la
production chute le blocus alliés réduit
les importations étrangle le commerce
maritime dans l'industrie on manque à la
fois de main d'oeuvre et de matières
premières
on fait la queue dans les magasins pour
obtenir des denrées alimentaires qui
bien souvent n'existent plus ou qui sont
des ersatz les allemands appellent ce
temps l'hiver au chaud
des millions d'hommes et de femmes
mangent des choux une ménagère allemande
se souvient de s'être gelé ventre creux
dans un foyer sans électricité
le pétrole est lui le manque et même la
grèce pour les bougies
la détresse est supporté par patriotisme
mais les artistes ne se gêne pas pour
illustrer aigrement la réalité
kate kollwitz par exemple dont le plus
jeune fils est mort au front
le dessinateur georges grèce soldats
réformer pour dépression nerveuse crocs
l'arrière du front sans aucune groupe
les ans ses dessins sont tout à fait
dans l'esprit des observations amer le
propre fils du désert
le conte prince j'ai vu dit-il un
changement immense et menaçant dans les
rues de berlin les gens des classes
moyennes ont perdu leur air satisfait
ils traînent dans les rues le teint pâle
les yeux creux dans des vêtements élimés
à leurs côtés piaf des profiteurs qui
les boudent skull pour prendre toute la
place
mais propagande officielle et glorifient
les as de l'aviation
les capitaines des sous marins les
généraux du front auto dicks en présente
les soldats comme des victimes dans la
guerre telle qu'il l'a peint il n'y a
pas de place pour la gloire
par eddie du quartier général tout ce
qu'il ya de meilleur sur le marché doit
être réquisitionnés pour l'armée le
dender demande au front intérieur de
supporter la misère de faire des
sacrifices
les besoins de l'armée premi
les citoyens mange du pain noir mais ils
doivent envoyer des colis aux armées
l'armée a priorité absolue ainsi et
éviter la révolution dans les lignes
dans les zones occupées de france de
belgique et de pologne
des unités de l'armée sont affectés au
travail dans les fermes pour être sûr
que les récoltes seront saisis à la
source les allemands de l'intérieur ne
recevront rien de tout cela
le travail forcé fourni de la main
d'oeuvre des régions occupées ainsi que
les camps de prisonniers de guerre mais
ces travailleurs supplémentaires sont
autant de bouches à nourrir une charge
de plus pour l'économie titubante et
cependant la main d'oeuvre étrangère est
essentiel dans les fermes dans les
usines les pour entretenir les voies de
communication avec le fonds
un prisonnier évadé raconte que grâce
aux colis de la croix rouge qu'il
recevait régulièrement ils mangeaient
mieux que ses gardiens
on récolte à domicile les objets en
métal pour nourrir la production de
guerre
on utilise la ferraille les batteries de
cuisine mais les gens donnent aussi
leurs anneaux d'or et leurs bijoux les
biens comme levi la guerre arraché ton
la dernière de laine sur le dos d'un
peuple déjà habitués ou plus terribles
prévention les industries allemandes si
puissante grésy sous l'effet d'une
tension excessive les matériels s'épuise
la puissance se perd les ingénieurs sont
au front traçant les plans de guerre
l'allemagne jadis si dynamics exténué
dans la grisaille d'un crépuscule de
guerre
le reichstag expriment le mécontentement
général au nom du désert une tentative
de paix est amorcée du côté des alliés
par le chancelier de bethmann vague
séides pitié devant une misère indicible
n'est-il pas possible de trouver une
base d'entente dit il mais les alliés de
son nullement prêt à négocier avec une
allemagne qui ne croit qu'à la force
le chancelier est il prêt à discuter sur
l'alsace et la lorraine
demandent les français le parti de la
paix une fois mises en échec le dender
fait hindenburg s'empare du contrôle du
gouvernement
la politique intérieure explique le
quartier-maître général doit être
dirigée par ceux qui sont responsables
des plans militaires
les généraux persuade le kayser de leur
accorder des pouvoirs ils veulent le 1er
février 1917
ils obtiennent de lui la liberté de
reprendre la guerre sous-marine intégral
qui pousse le président wilson à entrer
dans le conflit
les allemands croyait pouvoir être
anglais tranquillement la grande
bretagne sans que les états unis bouge
c'était la conviction du secrétaire
d'état allemand aux affaires étrangères
arthur lieberman l'amérique ne fera rien
dit il parce que wilson est pour la paix
et rien d'autre en février les sous
marins avait coulé 800 mille tonnes de
navires
seul un navire sur quatre quittant
l'angleterre revenait au port
l'ambassadeur américain à berlin a été
rappelé l'entrée en guerre des
etats-unis sauver la grande bretagne
mais le choix de la guerre totale par
l'allemagne
sauvé aux six pays de la révolution en
accordant les pleins pouvoirs à l'état
major
elle pousse l aventure jusqu'au bout